everybody pants now pants pants pants
pants pants she's had enough call it off
that's not how it works she's out wait
I'm subbing in April no that stuff will
melt the shell off a garden snail
whatever I'm Puerto Rican I can handle
it oh my
God okay this ends
now
yeah mom you're going back to the farm
and you you're going back to Hell fine I
got what I came for anyway I found your
underground safe I stole half your gold
that's decoy gold you think I'd leave my
gold in a locked safe buried underground
where anyone could find it you don't
know me at all yes I do I knew you the
minute you were born I intend to be
there the minute you
die Ron your family's
weird ready to go yes your keys
please you got to be kidding me I'm fine
well we let the chart be the judge of
that
what are you 5'11 210 lb three whiskies
looks like you just over the line into
impaired you carry that with you all the
time it comes in handy and on the back
it teaches you how to play Blackjack
Swanson's have a preternaturally high
tolerance for alcohol my old man used to
put wild turkey on his Corn Flakes I'm
not going to argue with you Ron we're
just going to sit and wait until you
know you're safe to drive which would be
in
about 1
hour insurance is a side bet when you
wager half of your original bet because
you believe the dealer has a 10 in the
hole get off my car woman 20 minutes the
dealer really has an advantage that's
what I get the most from
this hey
run morning Leslie did you have a good
night I did I watched a really good docu
what is that this is what I did last
night after I got home I drank six more
glasses of whiskey and then I finished
crafting this small harp using a band
saw a Spoke shave and an oscillating
spindle
sander beautiful but wait there's more
here are some photographs of me drinking
the whiskey you'll notice I'm holding up
yesterday's newspaper so you can tell
that I'm not
lying feel like I'm in a
spa
and the winner is Ron Swanson for
chair this award is the only one I'd
ever give a damn
about I made my first chair when I was
five but the quality of the wood was
wanting so when I turned nine I used my
factory wages to purch just some
beautiful local
Walnut uh thank
you for this uh this all good night good
uh there it
[Applause]
is now that's what I call shooting is
this a hunting game yeah it's fine you
want to play indeed I do if you'd like I
can offer you some pointers hunting
Donna is about silence balance and
patience get
ready okay you know you're supposed to
hit the deer
right get it together sson well the game
is absurd and this gun is lightweight
there's no sight and we are far too
close to these deer would they not smell
us I want my money back how do I get my
quarters oh my God you are such a sore
loser I not a sore loser it's just that
I prefer to win and when I don't I get
furious employe okay let's begin the
barbecue oh hey little guy what are you
doing oh no everyone meet your
meat on why are you doing this to us
well in my opinion not enough people
have looked their dinner in the eyes and
considered the circle of life this is
your dinner his name is
Tom burn seriously no I understand that
it's hilarious but that is his given
Christian name Tom is very smart and
Incredibly loyal he's basically a dog a
dog we're going to cook chew and swallow
dude there's kids around here good point
which one of you youngsters wants to
help me drain the blood from this animal
if you do a good job I'll give you the
bladder you can blow it up for a fun
playball Hey Ron you're not going to
slaughter that pig here are you not to
worry I have a
permit this just says I can do what I
want I am the director of the parks
department and this is a park it's not a
Parks thing it's against like three laws
and dozen Health
codes
fine barbecue is postponed until I can
go pick up some meat from the food and
stuff let's go Tom no Pig
[Music]
Tom we have a wonderfully small number
of Clues one is this ticket did you see
this movie about vampires and such New
Moon yeah I saw it with April she was so
hopped up on painkillers from getting
her wisdom teeth out I convinced her to
see it with me the teeth they're yours
you were super out of it you kept
yelling team Voldemort at the screen and
we were kicked out I was Furious you
only get to see the second Twilight film
for the seventh time once do you
remember anything about a key or April
doing anything unusual that day she did
make a stop by the shoe shine stand
before we left because she wanted to
drop something off for Andy she had a
real bad crush on him oh babe you had a
crush on me that's embarrassing we're
married still to the Sho shine
stand I just want to get the work over
as soon as possible so I can do some
fishing fishing relaxes me it's like
yoga except I still get to kill
something I mean yes my daughter might
think she is old enough to be sexual
active with their boyfriend but I'm
sorry 16 that that just seems too young
to be in birth control you know I was 24
when Gail took my virginity would say we
just stand here in
silence and think of
ideas for projects you know what I
should do I should lead a teen
abstinence
Workshop that might be incredibly
effective evening gentlemen oh hey R
hail zorp it is a beautiful night for
the end of the world congratulations to
all of you for reaching the Finish Line
the zories are ridiculous but like the
founding fathers I believe in absolute
freedom of religion also their
ceremonies require the playing of
flutes I happen to make flutes in my
wood shop flutes are $80 a piece and
Recorders are 150 hey they're
beautiful would you take a check you can
cash it to tomor tomorrow
[Laughter]
[Music]
sure that was Symphony for the righteous
destruction of humanity in E Minor by
the late Lou prvic reminder these flutes
are available for purchase you can't
take it with you people put your hands
together for the one the only my man Mr
Duke
Sila a mighty fine holiday evening to
you
all it might be cold
outside but it's about to get warm all
up in my
jazz I of course am Duke silver and I
would like to dedicate this first
song to my
[Music]
duchess
you're so
lucky I'm going to kill
[Music]
you